we were decrying and when I say we I
mean you know us on the Left we were
decrying ben shapiro coming because of
you know if there's gonna be violence
and because he's hateful and because of
this and because of that the reality was
that a group an tyfa was going to be the
they were gonna be the ones producing
that type of violence
i'm really glad to have this next guest
i think we agree on very little policy
wise but that's also i wanted to have
mon this guy has a brass pair he wrote
some articles yeah i think the salt lake
tribune he's actually one of the
founders of indivisible utah so and then
we'll take it from there you can follow
him on twitter at da giri a GUI our our
e84 this that's the gringo way for
announcing it donald Aguirre how are you
sir I'm good how are you doing I'm doing
well thank you you're taking your life
in your hands coming on the show first
off so we or she you said you had some
friends who wanted you to punch me
forcefully yeah they well they said
punch him hard for me yeah and then
somebody somebody told me that you were
gonna make me eat my lunch today
he brought a box lunch you know I I
would allow you to on-air it's important
relaxed atmosphere
well this stem from you know obviously
individual Utah the Ben Shapiro spoke
there and and we were there we did this
video on anta fo and I saw you posted
that video first off knows is that where
you got the the first reaction from your
colleagues so it came in two waves the
first the first reaction was when I when
I submitted that opinion piece to the
Tribune I got messages saying you sound
like a like a self-loathing liberal or a
hateful liberal to yourself right and
that was the first time and then the
second one was after the event when I
saw the video that you guys made not
made you guys didn't fabricate that I
mean I I saw the raw footage after after
you guys released a three-minute yeah
and and you know I I mean you got a call
it how it is I think when it comes to
bad behavior dangerous behavior I mean I
wasn't the only one the good thing is
that people on what I guess my side who
watched that video also had the reaction
of oh my god yeah what the hell is this
you know people who luring people back
to possibly hurt them I mean political
ideology kind of just it caught it falls
to the wayside like he that anybody who
is interested in in civil dialogue and
in our society can see that that's
that's not good right it's and so yeah I
got reactions when when I posted that
video in fact I got a reaction from
someone that was in that video I forget
the person's name but they they work at
the you okay and you guys you guys
called them out specifically that they
were encouraging some of this behavior
they made a comment on the Facebook
posts that you know when I share your
video and it kind of just went from
there and the funny thing is outside of
the hidden camera footage were released
the raw footage mostly was pulled from a
lot of news they go out of professors
matter activists and let me see this you
wrote in your piece you said listen Ben
Shapiro is a lot of things but he's not
a white nationalist so I put the answer
thing on the side and go back to it that
struck a chord with me because he's a
notorious Jewish Nazi I mean I get that
you probably disagree with Ben on a
whole lot sometimes I wanna I want to
lay one on him you know Ben is smug he's
but he's a brilliant kid let me ask you
this the left they call him a white
nationalist or they call him a Nazi as
someone who's not afraid to go against
the grain this is a genuine question
since you're more on the Left than I am
do you think they really believe Ben
Shapiro is a Nazi a white nationalist or
is it an attack that they use and how
they react when you say listen it's just
not accurate okay so I'm glad you asked
that because I really think that this
comes from a purely emotional place I
think I think it's coming from from raw
emotion of of angst and not knowing in
which direction to take that angst to
properly address the actual issue one I
think it's coming from it's coming from
from from up high
I guess when when when you have groups
that are being led by people that get
caught up in having to retain attention
I'm gonna call it out right now
I saw the video that Lex Scott said that
he's the most dangerous man on the
planet right and and that that's
ridiculous he's not the most dangerous
man on the planet I would say the leader
of North Korea
pootin Trump to a certain degree there's
some dangerous crap there when it comes
to people that can make these big
decisions that affect your lives ben
shapiro i don't know what is he weighed
150 pounds 160 pounds I'm not gonna do
the carnival barking because he's doing
Crossfit so I don't want to get it wrong
yeah but he's a fit fit compact man I'm
probably probably in the ballpark yeah
and not only that you know did you watch
his speech by the way I did so I I woke
up the day that the tickets were being
distributed I got up at 6:00 a.m. and I
thought I'm getting up at 6:00 I'll
Drive to the you they use only like a
30-minute drive from where I live I'll
get a ticket because I want to attend I
want to go watch this and I got there
and there was already like 1500 people
in line okay and they had like 400
tickets you know so I wasn't able to get
in but I went to the event anyway and I
hung outside and I interviewed people I
talked to trump supporters ben shapiro
supporters i talked to a bunch of people
and i in since i couldn't get in i had
it playing on the youtube link that was
available so i listened to that on the
audio while i interacted with people
after at the rally that was outside and
the one thing i can say is that every
single side does not have all the
information they have pieces of
information that made me fit their
narratives but they don't know the
entire story
I asked Trump supporters did you know
that should that ben shapiro supported
ted cruz they had no idea i asked people
if they knew that ben shapiro was a jew
they had no idea so there's a lot of a
lot of missing information that i think
caused emotions to run high on on all
the different side did you pull a large
sampling of blind people who couldn't
see the yarmulke if you know you have to
ask it a certain point go and there's a
plus/minus of a hundred percent here
yeah it really i mean i so i i watched
you and the funny thing is the first
time i saw your stuff i thought is this
guy a liberal is he conservative where
does he fall on things cuz it was fun it
was funny to me as someone who i guess
you know after this people will say
you're not even on the left you're not a
liberal you're you're capitulating to
the right you're this and you're that
here what they say I know what I think
sure the first time I saw your video I
thought I don't know where this guy
stands and then I watched more of them
like oh okay this guy has a conservative
slant on things which is fine sure and
and then I went down that little rabbit
hole looking at ben shapiro videos i've
looked at at milo videos i've looked at
a variety of things and and at the end
of it all all you have to do i think
that the arguments that were being
presented sucked on the left made us
look stupid i think because we didn't
know all the facts we're calling this
guy and not see a white nationalist
someone oh he's he's part of the
alt-right oh he supported donald trump I
watched ben shapiro laughing his ass off
the night of the election when Trump won
because he thought it was so ridiculous
he thought it was like this guy won
right and he was laughing so and that
only took me a couple clicks to find
well then L tribalism that you see I
mean listen you know we in the primaries
I support pretty much everyone but Trump
when I came to the Trump versus Hillary
okay I see the argument but people just
go you're you're an alt right Trump
supporter it doesn't matter what you are
that's an umbrella term that's been used
but let me ask you this going back to
the first off did you hear anything
particularly incendiary in Ben's
specific speech at Utah okay there's one
thing that stood out to me okay I wasn't
I wasn't I wasn't calling you know an
emergency line to talk me off the ledge
about it right I looked at it as an
opportunity there was one situation
there was one specific moment in the in
his talk where he was talking to
somebody that I know that was in the
audience who is the chair to one of the
Democratic parties and one of the
counties here in Utah and the question
was about societal value of gay marriage
of same-sex marriage and and ben shapiro
started off with you know if we're
talking about promiscuity and if we're
talking about maybe the spread of
disease and yes there's a societal value
there and and I heard that and I thought
he did that on purpose he obviously did
that on purpose
I know that he's he'll app he'll let
liberals or people that lean to the left
to ask questions first he lets them ask
questions first that's in the front so I
know that and so I know that that was
that was kind of a setup he's also and
he's entertaining the crowd it's not
like
he's not you know and then it went into
the whole if we're gonna define you know
the value of marriage it has nothing to
do with those things it has everything
to do with the reproduction of children
with the production of children and the
person who asked this question by the
way who's the chair of the Democratic
Party in Utah County is gay and so it
was very civil it was like okay then
that's it he sat down and that was the
end of it I know that there were people
that watched that and said oh this guy
is hateful he hates gays he hates this
type of person and that type of person
when that's not the argument that should
be made the argument that should have
been made I think and I'm not a
constitutional lawyer I think Ben
Shapiro is a constitutional lawyer I'm
not exactly sure what is law practices
but yeah the argument to be made is if
we're gonna define that value of
marriage is the production of children
then how do we explain heterosexual
couples that don't that can produce
children you know if it's if it's
children themselves then you know what
about same-sex marriages that same such
same-sex parents that raise children
they give a stable home in the house
sure you know there's a lot of viable
arguments that could be made that could
be based off studies that could be based
off facts but getting caught up in
emotional getting hooked by that you
lose right so it was immediately I don't
want to get into a debate we're gonna be
back on to actually debate issues
recover you know have a conversation
about issues when we disagree
I would have loved to hear that
conversation but I guess sort of in a
nutshell nothing that been said was
deliberately incendiary or hateful I
just wanted to make sure you know I
don't want anyone here since I know
you're more left to think that you have
to defend everything Ben said that's not
what this is about
going back to the antiphon issue I know
you're you're more liberal but I think
we'd probably both agree that the media
leans to the left did you feel as though
maybe your eyes were opened a little bit
again this is truly just it's it's I'm
not fishing for an answer
but if someone who's been on the right
and it said before this happened I said
the media no matter what happens to me
he's not going to want to cover this on
anti-fur they're not going to want to
cover even if it is violent we never
expected it to be as bad as it was but
seeing the media having access to the
same footage that the FBI had access to
which led to the arrest of one of these
people saying no no we're not going to
cover it did that concern you at all as
someone who's more liberal and knows
that the media tends to lean your way
I'll tell you what concerned me what
concerned me was the
journalistic integrity that needs to
exist when we went when a journalist
when someone wants to deliver the news
and by the way I'm I'm a university
student and I'm studying journalism and
that that's something that I enjoyed
very much I love to read and so I want
to know facts and I want to know well
what was the story give me the facts and
let's see let's let's dissect that the
fact that that was just kind of glossed
over and and the only because the only
video I saw came from from this from
this YouTube channel I didn't see it
coming out anywhere else right I didn't
see someone debunk you guys and say hey
we went behind and looked at what
Crowder did nothing like that came out
and so what concerned me the most is the
fact that this was this was a factual
thing that happened this this this
looked like a truthful event this this
thing occurred and you went to them and
told them hey this happened I have the
footage I have as a journalist I would
want to at least look at this I would
like to vet that information and then
put it in the news like I I would that's
that's that's what my biggest concern
was yeah because because there needs to
be in integrity when when there is a
delivery of the news or when you're
discussing the fact if you're gonna
discuss an opinion or an editorial then
obviously it's editorialized you're
gonna have your own subjective view on
that which is completely fine that's
what we expect from an editorial but
that wasn't an editorial this was a fact
this is what happened yeah you know it's
give more leeway and say we edit oriole
eyes based on what happened you know we
went in and we thought that you know
screaming you know we've had them spit
on people or throw stuff but when they
handed page here Dan was an icepick that
was wasn't that a nice pitch at night
I'm not up to date a shank ship I don't
know that verb versus noun when that
happened he texts us that they just
handed me a knife and a shiv and they're
going to get more it was said we pulled
them out so then we went right away to
the police to the feds see and the media
yeah the police the authorities took it
right away took him into a van I didn't
see him for two hours and media said no
no don't nothing about this that was
what was crazy to me so two things one
excellent thinking on not knowing where
to go take us to get out of that
situation
remember to number
- here's what I would like to know I
would like to know you know what if safe
like let's say Fox News would have been
there who many say well that's that's a
conservative that's a conservative news
channel or let's say a conservative news
outlet would have been there do you
think you would have gotten the same
response from them or do you or do you
think that the you didn't get a response
to them solely on the fact that you feel
that they lean more to the left that
they're more liberal media well you know
what that's an interesting question
because there's a lot of inside baseball
you know I worked at Fox for four and a
half years I will say this they would
have been more interested if it were
just a generic person coming forward
with this story right but news outside
of let's remove sort of the politics
from it they're so focused on getting a
scoop and an exclusive and not just
reporting the actual news they might not
if it were me because they know they
have a big enough channel I've had
people at big news networks coming in
say hey listen listen can you give this
to us exclusively I said it's going
online well we don't want to use it then
we don't want to cover the story so IDIA
logically yeah Fox leans to the right
not as far right as people think with
this you know we're the redheaded
stepchild listen we this is editorial
ization this is the podcast that grew
beyond you know our wildest imagination
and we tend to have a platform I don't I
can't answer that question for me I
think Fox would have taken it if it were
just some random person with a story I
do I I know that I'm not sure if you if
you guys over there have recently seen
it just came out yesterday or the day
before the Washington Post had a they
released something on a woman who had
approached them from they say she came
out of a building in the New York
offices as a project Veritas Oh so James
O'Keefe thing that James O'Keefe thing
and you know this is something that you
know I I feel that the media as a whole
just needs to be better overall I mean
the news would be much more boring I
think but it's it's more like we get
constant analysis of things and we beat
it to death that is just constant
analysis constant analysis there's
always breaking news of the same I'm
sorry don't worry about it
it's the same it's the same stuff that
just keeps coming out when the reality
should be that you know like this
information like that that specific
video I seriously was shocked my friend
and I but couple buddies of mine that
work with me I show them the video and
they will
oh my god I was planning on going there
I was gonna take my wife or you know I
would have gone with my kids I would
have I would have gone there and then
they saw that video and I thought why
wasn't this on the news why didn't
nobody report this why did this not get
reported and so you know it's it's one
of those things where we were decrying
and when I say we I mean you know us on
the Left we were decrying ben shapiro
coming because of you know if there's
gonna be violence and because he's
hateful and because of this and because
of that the reality was that a group
auntie fuh was going to be the they were
gonna be the ones producing that type of
violence if you're came down to that
luckily it did not I'm so glad that
didn't happen but you know I've been
getting flack for calling out auntie
from the very beginning well
specifically aunt I thought why have you
chosen before our video to not get
behind anti and why is it so hard for
the left you know it's not hard for me
to say hey the rallies were the guys of
the tiki torches we're not with them
that's just as disgusting to me and
running somewhere the Dodge Challenger
awful terrible why is that the left
can't do the same thing when aids but
whether they're sucker punching people
at an airport or this is happening in
Utah and why did you have the foresight
it's I don't understand it because it
seems like you're reasonable I would
imagine there are more like you on the
left than plenty we'd like to believe
plenty plenty plenty I you know I wish I
could answer that with 100% certainty
but I think what it comes down to it is
again it comes down to a level of angst
there's a level of anxiety that needs to
be talked down but in order to for it to
be talked down people have to be open to
listen I think losing or ceding the
moral high ground or move any moral
ground for the forget the high ground
but seating any sort of moral position
to a group that incites violence doesn't
win the public over and and I think
looking at peaceful protests honest
dissent that that is done in a peaceful
way that's done in a way to where you're
bringing in more voices that whole level
of inclusion to get your ideas off the
ground that's proven to be more
successful always will be more
successful than any sort of violent you
know tactic you you you at that
you risk the eyeballs of the public to
go along with you you you risk them just
stopped listening to you by doing that
but but I think that it comes down to
the fact that some of these groups and
some of them I know these people
personally I know that they're they're
well-intentioned when it comes to he
know I'm just really scared
well that fear and that anxiety can only
be brought down with more reading with
more self investigation with your own
opinion I I was a registered Democrat
and I was a Democratic delegate and I'm
still registered as a delegate for them
but now I'm an unaffiliated voter and
the reason I went that route is because
I want to be free I want to be free of
any sort of political party that tells
me I have to go this way and have to go
that way I don't wanna be used as a pawn
I'd rather I'd rather make up my own
mind on those things you know and some
people might say oh you got red pills or
something headline red pills
okay well listen don't we do have to go
I would love to hatchback I appreciate
you taking the time and listen I think
what you're talking about we took a big
risk with the change my mind second
that's just real conversations
completely unedited we have three of
them and it will go on for an hour
people watch them and they're getting
over a million plays it's the opposite
of cable news it is sit down
listen change my mind or I change yours
that's it and I do think there are a lot
of people out there like yourself who
are willing to listen to have a
conversation by the way it doesn't mean
that you don't need you you can't have
firm disagreements you've or watch
irrelevant
you don't watch how they insult each
other very politely but it's pretty
rough all right we do have to go eight
is at D Aguirre da GUI RR e 8e for show
him you love him my guess is you'll be
getting a call from Dave Rubin next
Donald thank you for being on the show
sir have me again man I'd love to come
on
absolutely we'll be back like this video
subscribe by clicking the button that
says subscribe if not there's a strong
chance that you're an armenian genocide
denier wink wink
i think you know what i'm talking about
but i don't over there this isn't the
channel for you i'm sure you'll find
something there that you deem very
insightful and informative also i
request that you come back here
afterward and immediately leave a
negative comment because we read those
and those affect our lives directly we
care about them because we care about
you